merci pour ces précisions deuxième gros
titres de l'actualité de ce mercredi des
enfants à vendre sur internet
une histoire incroyable d'abord la
méthode petite annonce sur internet pour
adopter deux petites jumelles
américaines contre une poignée de
dollars puis ensuite il ya eu une
embrouille
elles ont été adoptés par un couple
américain la mère biologique les
récupère et les revend un couple
britannique je voulais dit c'est
vraiment une histoire incroyable laurent
bousquet pour les détails à 6 mois
kimberley et belinda ne se rendent
évidemment pas compte qu'elles sont au
centre d'une histoire peu commune
une de ces folies qui mêle internet
l'avidité des agences d'adoption et le
désespoir de parents qui veulent à tout
prix avoir des enfants
tout commence sur le site web d'une
agence américaine spécialisée dans les
adoptions par internet
judith et alan qu'il chauffe originaire
du pays de galles et adopte contre une
somme de 8000 200 livres environ 85
mille francs deux soeurs jumelles nées
en californie après un court passage
dans un autre état américain l'arkansas
tour et signer des certificats le couple
ramène les deux petites filles au pays
de galles
un retour mouvementé il faut dire
qu'entre temps judith et allen avait
découvert et bail que les deux soeurs
avaient déjà été adoptées certains
diront vendu pour 4000 livres 43 mille
francs par le même site internet à un
autre couple vivant lui en californie
la police nous a recommandé de partir
très vite pour notre sécurité elle on
lit que l'autre couple pouvait devenir
violent ils ont dit que nous ne faisions
rien d'illégal mais qu'il ne voulait pas
que nous restions que les formes et avec
l'aide de l' agence d'adoption la mère
biologique aurait ainsi touché deux fois
le prix de ses enfants
un drame évidemment pour les deux
couples adoptants qui se traite de
menteur et s'invectivent par télévision
interposée et qu'ils vont tout faire
maintenant pour garder ou récupérer les
deux petites filles
un drame humain qui se double
aujourd'hui d'un problème international
le couple américain ayant saisi le fbi
haye pour enlèvement d'enfants
l'angleterre répliquant par la voix de
son ministre de l'intérieur
crosby bien sûr ce problème inquiète je
trouve révoltant idée de vendre et
d'acheter des enfants c'est illégal
en grande bretagne les sites internet
spécialisés dans l'adoption se sont
multipliés ces dernières années
profitant du manque de législation
internationale dans ce domaine
certains y ont vu un marché sans limite
où l'on peut gagner des millions en
vendant bruit en vendant le mot n'est
pas trop fort en vendant donc des
enfants à des adultes désespéré de ne
pouvoir en adopter par les moyens
classiques l'aide